[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente el comil 19 no impidió que
los nicaragüenses celebrarán sus fiestas
aunque con capacidad limitada y algunos
cubrebocas los habitantes de diriamba
ahorraron a su patrono san sebastián
y dos aliados del presidente de brasilia
bolsonaro fueron elegidos como jefes de
ambas cámaras del congreso poniendo en
jaque los pedidos de destitución
parlamentaria que se estaban lanzando en
su contra por su gestión de la pandemia
y los llevo a conocer a la congresista
republicana a quien el líder de este
partido en el senado mitch mcconnell ha
acusado de difundir teorías de la
conspiración y quién podría darle vida
al trompo
y vamos de inmediato a nicaragua para
nuestra historia principal mientras los
médicos alertan sobre una nueva ola de
contagios de kobe 19 en el país
centroamericano la falta de medidas
oficiales permiten realizar actividades
masivas en las calles de ese país
nuestro corresponsal jorge hurtado fue
hasta diriamba al sur de managua donde
los devotos de san sebastián le
rindieron homenaje desde allí nos brinda
detalles de las aglomeraciones que
persisten a pesar de la pandemia
en diriamba al sur de nicaragua y una
pandemia puede interrumpir las fiestas
patronales cada año centenares festejan
a san sebastián con un colorido atuendo
que representa el mestizaje ahora con
tapabocas incluidos
primeramente hay menos personas por el
miedo
por el miedo prácticamente y pues
tenemos que estar ocupando mascarillas
el uso del alcohol a cada rato y este
año no todos los bailantes podemos
entrar a la basílica
[Música]
marlon flores es el líder de este grupo
de más de 100 bailarines creel al igual
que el resto de tradicionalistas
participan para seguir un legado
familiar por cumplir una promesa defensa
el pueblo deberían bueno un pueblo pele
un pueblo que le rinde mucho fervor al
patrón san sebastián entonces pues hemos
venido adecuando no y tomando las
medidas sanitarias para poder celebrar
estas festividades de san sebastián en
la iglesia el exceso es limitado pero en
las afueras la municipalidad montó
tarimas y bailes para que las personas
festejan bajo una peligrosa normalidad
que se vive desde que llegó la pandemia
y que ha sido criticada por médicos
independientes es evidente que estamos
en lo que llamaríamos la segunda ola
apenas estamos digamos en la en la
subida hacia
lo que es esta segunda ola no sabemos si
va a ser tan grande como la primera o
más pequeña no lo sabemos todavía pero
si estamos claro de que esto ha sido
determinado por las denominaciones que
se han dado antes porque en el país hay
una falsa seguridad de control del virus
del cual no se ha hecho las autoridades
registran desde el inicio de la pandemia
168 fallecidos por kobe mientras
sociedad civil denuncia que las cifras
reales rondan los 3.000 fallecidos en
nicaragua nunca se ordenó ningún tipo de
confinamiento en cambio festejos como
estos son promovidos constantemente
el presidente de brasilia air bolso raro
anotó un gol con el nombramiento de dos
de sus aliados como presidentes de ambas
cámaras del congreso una victoria muy
necesitada para él ya que ha estado
enfrentando llamados de los legisladores
a iniciar un juicio político en el
senado con miras a su destitución por su
gestión de la pandemia el congreso de
brasil ha elegido a dos nuevos líderes y
ambos son cercanos a jair bolsonaro
remojar tu vida el nuevo presidente de
la cámara de diputados- y rodrigo
pacheco el nuevo presidente del senado
desempeñará en el papel de guardianes de
la política brasileña con el poder de
decidir qué legislación se debate y se
vota y más importante el presidente de
la cámara baja tiene el poder de aceptar
o desestimar las mociones para iniciar
un juicio político con miras a la
destitución del presidente que habían
estado en el radar del anterior portavoz
de esta cámara y de decenas de
parlamentarios durante meses
posicionaron enfrenta varias mociones de
impeachment incluidas 20 por su manejo
caótico de la pandemia el presidente
brasileño a menudo se ha negado sólo una
mascarilla y aquí
las restricciones impuestas por los
alcaldes hace unos días se realizaron
mítines en varias ciudades brasileñas
para protestar contra el líder de
derecha
esta es una protesta nacional contra
bolsonaro a favor de la vacuna y la
devolución de la ayuda financiera de
emergencia brasil está en una fuerte
crisis la gente se está muriendo
escenas similares se repitieron en la
capital brasilia los manifestantes allí
hicieron mímicas de una muerte por
asfixia aludiendo a la grave escasez de
oxígeno en algunas partes del país
esto aquí no es top bo sonar para ti sí
estoy aquí para decir basta de este
gobierno genocida de este gobierno que
ataca los derechos humanos que ataca al
pueblo brasileño a la salud pública y
aquí estamos en consecuencia de este
desgobierno con más de 220 mil muertes
por culpa de kobe basta de bolsonaro
juicio político ya sé que debo sonar y
pizza
el último escándalo que salpica al
gobierno es el gasto en alimentos para
la administración federal que aumentó un
20% más que el año anterior uno de los
números más asombrosos es el de la leche
condensada 23 millones de euros
suficiente para dos o tres toneladas por
día
sin embargo bolsonaro se lo está tomando
todo con calma en este vídeo se le ve
burlándose del escándalo intercambiando
latas de leche condensada con un
youtuber brasileño el hombre de 65 años
ya tiene los ojos puestos en su campaña
de reelección en 2022
revisamos la imagen de la semana ella es
mayor y taylor greene una congresista
republicana por el estado de georgia
solo una republicana más en la cámara de
representantes pero simboliza la lucha
interna dentro del partido su castigo
por comentarios extremos podría
significar el nacimiento del trump ismo
como movimiento político
creyente de las teorías de la
conspiración de extrema derecha de
hernán y defensora acérrima de donald
trump la voz de mayor y taylor greene se
ha alzado en el congreso vendiendo ideas
racistas y antisemitas ha acosado a
víctimas de tiroteos en la escuela
secundaria después de haber asegurado
que los ataques fueron organizados algo
que posteriormente tuvo que retirar y
apoyó además la violencia contra los
demócratas la decisión de despojar o no
a la representante por georges de 46
años de la oposición puede enfurecer a
los partidarios de las locas mentiras y
las teorías de conspiración son un
cáncer para el partido republicano y
nuestro país
alguien que sugirió que quizá ningún
avión chocó contra el pentágono el 11 de
septiembre que los horribles tiroteos
escolares fueron actuados y que los
clinton se estrellaron contra el avión
de john fitzgerald kennedy juniors no
está viviendo en la realidad a lo que la
representante replicó en las redes
sociales que el verdadero cáncer para el
partido republicano son los republicanos
débiles que solo saben perder
gracias los continuos reclamos de
marguerite taylor 20 que donald trump
ganó las elecciones y que joe biden
debería ser acusado reflejan las
convicciones de parte de la base
republicana los legisladores lo saben y
algunos incluso están presionando para
que se sancione a los republicanos que
votaron a favor del juicio político
contra trump maniobras que ilustran que
el partido republicano está dividido en
sus ideales y en su próximo capítulo
también en eeuu la estrella del rock
marilyn manson se quedó sin disquera por
señalamientos de abuso sexual la ex
pareja del cantante grace jones work
públicamente aseguró que abusó de ella
durante años a lo que él llamó
distorsiones de la realidad veamos más
en el siguiente informe en 2018 evan
rachel week compartió su experiencia
como sobrevivientes de abuso sexual ante
el congreso en ese momento no nombró a
su agresor
gui qing me despertaba junto al hombre
que decía amarme y que violaba lo que él
creía que era mi cuerpo inconsciente lo
peor de todo fueron los rituales de
las manos y los pies para torturar
mental y físicamente hasta que mi
atacante sintió que le había demostrado
mi amor
tres años después la actriz
estadounidense ha revelado el nombre
acusando a su ex el cantante marilyn
manson como su abusador el nombre de mi
abusador es brian warner también
conocido en el mundo como marilyn manson
comenzó a manipular me cuando era
adolescente y abuso horriblemente de mí
durante años desde esta acusación
pública otras cuatro ex novias han
presentado desgarradoras historias de
acoso amenazas y violación
todas ellas describieron a mansión como
un manipulador violento rose mcgowan una
figura destacada del movimiento mito y
expareja de manson se apresuró a mostrar
su apoyo a las mujeres
estoy disgustada pero estoy
especialmente orgullosa de evan rachel
wood y las otras mujeres que denunciaron
a marilyn manson se necesita también
para llegar allí y estoy orgullosa de
esas mujeres y todas aquellas que se
enfrentan a su agresor
mi arte y mi vida siempre han suscitado
controversias pero estas declaraciones
sobre mí son horrendas distorsiones de
la realidad a pesar de las negaciones
del cantante su sello musical y su
agente han cortado lazos con él los
creadores de la serie de televisión
american watts también lo han eliminado
de los próximos episodios
el hombre que fundó y construyó el
gigante del comercio electrónico amazon
da un paso y se retira de su posición de
sí
jeff bezos se entrega el reino pero va a
permanecer como presidente ejecutivo
las ganancias de amazon se han
multiplicado durante la pandemia y la
compañía que ve a sus inició en su
garaje lo ha hecho el hombre más rico
del mundo
en un paso al costado de las operaciones
diarias después de casi 30 años
jeff bezos dice que no se jubilará sino
que está cambiando su enfoque hacia
nuevas iniciativas
como presidente ejecutivo seguiré
participando en importantes iniciativas
de amazon pero también tendré el tiempo
y la energía que necesito para
concentrarme en el day one found el beso
de heart font blue origin de washington
post' y mis otras pasiones lo que
comenzó en un garaje como una humilde
librería en línea se ha transformado en
una de las empresas más influyentes del
mundo con un valor de casi 17 billones
de dólares y ha convertido a besos en
uno de los hombres más ricos del mundo
con una fortuna estimada en casi 200.000
millones de dólares conocida como la
tienda de todo
amazon ahora produce películas vende
comestibles es líder en servicios de
computación en la nube y un rival cada
vez mayor de fedex ups en logística y
besos seguirá teniendo una amplia
influencia sobre la empresa cuando
amazon no es el primero ni el último
innovador que revolucionará el mercado
pero lo significativo de lo que ha hecho
diez veces es la magnitud de esa
interrupción sabes que hay muy pocos
mercados que de alguna manera han
permanecido intactos como resultado de
lo que amazon se ha convertido
ha habido obstáculos en el camino
incluidas disputas laborales y tensiones
con los reguladores amazon se enfrenta
actualmente a múltiples investigaciones
tanto en el país como en el extranjero
sobre sus prácticas de competencia
vamos a perú el zoológico de lima
celebró el nacimiento de dos cocodrilos
americanos una especie en peligro de
extinción luego de su concepción a
través de inseminación artificial
con coco y la pinta me despido pero
recuerden que pueden seguirme en redes
sociales en la dirección que ven en sus
pantallas cuídense mucho y sigan viendo
france24
[Música]
siempre que hay un líder asesinado